[Music]
as we all know the pandemic has thrown
into stark relief every day ethical
dilemmas that we face and has shone a
spotlight on the radical inequalities of
our society at both a national and a
global level most people agree that we
must protect the most vulnerable but who
are the vulnerable all the people and
people with underlying health conditions
but also essential workers front line
bus drivers shop workers care workers
who are also often the most underpaid
people in our society there are also
people suffering and cramped housing
with no outside space and there are
women suffering increased levels of
domestic violence so how do we weigh up
the value of different human lives do we
just have to accept the suffering of a
few to save the lives of many
or is that an obscene question with us
to discuss these major issues ah Susan
Nieman philosopher and director of the
Einstein Forum in Potsdam her most
recent book is called learning from the
Germans race and the memory of evil
which explores the lessons the US could
learn from Germany in coming to terms
with its terrible legacy then we have
patricia churchland professor of
philosophy america at the university of
california san diego who is well known
for her work on mind morality and who
instituted the idea of neuro philosophy
our most recent book is called
conscience and finding we are joined by
Peter Hitchens a journalist author and
broadcaster author of books such as the
abolition of Britain and the abolition
of Liberty he writes at the moment for
the mail on Sunday well I now I'm going
to open this debate up and ask each
speaker to give us their thoughts on the
debate and in particular to ask their
views on the question
is morality inherently selfish so I'll
begin if I may with you Susan
morality is exactly what we need when
other things clash with our
self-interest morality is exactly what
self-interest is relatively simple you
have to do some instrumental reasoning
sometimes to figure out what's in your
self-interest and and you know the best
way to go about getting the shortest
means to the ends that you want but
that's not a serious or philosophical
problem philosophical problems arise
when something that's in your
self-interest isn't in someone else's
and you you need to weigh things I mean
the basic answer to the question is
morality ultimately selfish is no but
what I've been thinking about since the
pandemic started is actually that the
entire very long discussion about
self-interest and the common good is
actually being undermined in a quite
promising and beautiful way and one
example of course is just what we're all
being told about wearing masks we're
wearing masks not to protect ourselves
but to protect other people and if they
wear masks it will protect us I mean
that's just a rock bottom level and a
perhaps a paradigm but also what you
mentioned at the beginning our
realization that not only our grocery
store workers and trash collectors and
you know nurses the most vulnerable and
usually the worst paid there are also
the most important all of us who get to
stay at home and work online and jabber
and conversations like this source file
our stories are non-essential the world
will go on turning without us and I
think there's been enough consciousness
of that and discussion of that all over
the world that people are beginning to
ask
it is not an act of generosity to make
sure that those people who keep the woo
keep our world's going are given the
same kinds of we're better working
conditions pay status and respect than
they have hitherto received because the
world will not go on turning if it
doesn't happen that way thank you very
much
Patricia can I ask each one's the same
question well I'll give it a shot and
I'm going to come at it from a different
direction I'm going to start with the
question that Darwin asked in the
descent of man in 1871 and Darwin knew
very well of course that mammals and
birds generally are intensely social the
doorman said where does our moral sense
or our conscience come from and he
suggested that it had three components
one is instinct one is learning and the
third is what we might call
problem-solving or reasoning now by and
large evolutionary biologists have been
disinclined to thinking that instinct
could be any part of the story because
they think gee you know if some person
had the instinct to be altruistic then
the other guys would take advantage of
them he wouldn't be able to reproduce
and it would be wiped out but it turned
out that there is an interesting story
about why mammals and birds are social
in the way that they are so about 200
million years ago warm-blooded animals
appeared on the planet now this was a
tremendous ecological advantage because
they can forage at night and they could
forage in cooler places but it came with
a huge cost gram for gram a warm-blooded
animal has to eat ten times as much so
in order to accommodate that those
animals warm-blooded were favored if
they were smart and the smarter the
better
now there's really two ways to get smart
one is to build it all in the jeans but
that's an extremely long and slow
process the other way is to learn and
the bigger the learning the smarter you
are and so what really happened then was
that big learning took place but the
downside the cost of big learning is
because the brain has to build structure
every time you learn anything infants
have to be born very immature and that
means they are very vulnerable so those
animals were favored where the parents
are in particular the mother formed
strong bonds to the infant and cared for
the infant as though it was an extension
of herself that she took care of its
food its warmth and safety now it wasn't
because it was fun it was because she
was wired to do this and we now know
it's something about the neural
chemicals that are involved in that and
they have to do with oxytocin and neural
chemicals that make you feel really good
the endocannabinoids now as species
traveled the planet and found additional
niches different manners and ways of
being social emerged some animals found
it very convenient to live in fairly
large groups some animals found that
para bond long term pair bonding was an
ecological advantage others didn't have
pair bonding but there was bonding
between kin bonding between friends and
so forth so if I can put it in a very
simple way but first I should make one
clarification by a moral decision here
I'm going to mean a decision in which I
am cursed in order to benefit another so
in the case of many social animals what
we see is that
there is significant caring for others
it says though to put it in a very
highly simplified way and I'm sure you
know I'll get beat up for this it's as
though bonding baguettes caring and
caring baguettes morality and we see
aspects of caring for others in the all
of the intensely social animals such as
wolves elephants baboons and certainly
also in humans now the learning part of
what Darwin kicked up on involves the
reward system so very early on the
infant's learn how to navigate their
social world but their reward system is
deeply involved so that when they
produce a behavior that is rewarded they
feel good they get a dopamine hit when
they produce behavior for which they are
scolded they get a serotonin hit to put
it simply and so it does mean and and
and I know some contents think that this
is horrifying it does mean that we often
take real pleasure in doing the right
thing in doing the good thing we derive
satisfaction and joy and pleasure from
doing that we also know that if you are
a social animal and you behave in these
socially caring ways that it's good not
only for your mental health it's also
very good for your physical health
it doesn't precisely imply anything
about policy for that I think we have to
figure out things in the way we always
have we have to come together compromise
make decisions do the best we can and by
and large with the exception of
Psychopaths
people tend to want to do that that they
are they have common sense basically
they are decent and when there is an
emergency people respond very well they
do respond in different
weights because we are different from
one another and that reflects our
cultural background but it also reflects
certain deep innate character illogical
features such as whether we are very
inclined to be rule-bound or whether we
are inclined to be rule-breakers and
there's really important data about that
but this is just by way of saying that
the mix is very complex and there is no
simple rule that tells us what the right
thing to do is okay thank you very much
and now finally I turn to 2 Peter
morality seems to me to be tested most
of all in the overcoming of fear to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas